yeah I used to put jelly and hairs as a
kid yeah spiky hair oh yeah yeah yeah I
had the colored
like the
blue I I didn't I didn't actually could
she go see you brother because I'm
actually aligned okay right no but I had
it you didn't ever have like the boy
band gel with the color in it like you
could get like blue or red gel it wasn't
the brown you could do like frosted tips
with ice yes it was yeah that didn't hit
my demographic we didn't get that
commercial
oh no no you knew what it was on the
bottle it was like a white dude with
like Liberty spikes
was it a yellow canister no it might be
look this the [__] look at all
that's who I wanted to look like yeah
and you picked that up saying Hell yeah
where'd you get haircuts man
um I don't like I really yeah like where
did I yeah like I think this place
called uh
Bean something
it was something I think Bean was in the
name beam
I don't know
what does a dude named Bean what sport
Globes yeah high grade you've never
heard of Sport Clips oh man yeah
Sport Clips is a it's a chain like a
super episode we're good no no that's
like a Super Cuts yeah they said High
grades and low Fades yeah
[__] bad yeah I agree it's low fat
I'm mad at the you know I mean back to
school fresh cut I I [__] with it this
is some serious marketing for a haircut
yeah yeah we don't get this at the black
joints mom I'll tell you that [__] man
but I've never seen like just a white
little chilling Barber Shop like I mean
we got like small black barber shops all
over I never just seen like mics
our haircut price is soaring in your
uh no this place is 30 bucks was that
it's 30. I paid 30 bucks plus tips so I
pay 32 bucks
35th
free burritos free Fritos you know
Friday
hey bro that's how they line you up they
actually pull out that F and they put on
the side of your head
yeah I'm here for the free Fritos I
actually didn't get my chips damn the
bar goes right across the ear so they
know when to stop
30 30 how much plus beard
I don't I don't have to be here no but
you've seen the menu oh I don't know
okay you get your beard done yeah man
and that was that's what jacks up the
price really yeah it is this so what
price do you guys pick bro we're in the
uh at least 100. that's what we have
to full service yeah that's [__] up
72 bucks yeah my girl like she has a
little machine yeah oh that's it but
it's like 45 seconds it's not enough you
know I just start to feel good and then
she stops I'm like [__] is that done
prepared man or maybe it's just because
of the tip yeah
y'all used to have the posters as kids
on the wall like that one number eight
yeah yeah
um yeah for sure
yeah I used to add hair sometimes can I
get 24. yeah can I get a seven and a
twelve yeah
[Laughter]
my hairdresser has the best Ranch
I like how every Barbershop has this
poster but it's the one they bought in
97 yeah and it's just that oh yeah let's
stop making these after 91. yeah sorry
it's the last one man definitely did
it's so there are no modern versions of
this no it's so faded like all the white
people like on the poster are gone like
it's just their eyes and like they're
dead but also like they're faded off
like it just it's just like kind of the
haircut and then you see an eyebrow yeah
the sun [__] baked that [__] off yeah
can I get those yeah yeah yeah
yeah
cold though man I remember one time we
went oh man a Jamaican Barbershop a
super old Jamaican bar shot all these
guys were like my grandfather's age and
they had this poster up and I sit down
on probably like 10. and he's like oh
what do you want and I'm just like um
number 14. he said I can't do that sit
down
you get
you just didn't care
that made me [__]
[Laughter]
it's a struggle to find a good one like
look at the kid three rows up in the
middle kid is like two years old and has
never actually had a haircut who were
the clippers but who would request that
yeah let me get that baby cut
you're growing man yeah yeah
all hair bro they just line up the front
[Laughter]
laughs
sorry it's a reflex no we're good
wife's calling
oh man
I've seen a barber chair on the side why
would they put that on there
purple child and stuck it on there yeah
who's that older guy with like the
[__] um you know with the receding
hairline that's crazy yeah 18. I guess
these aren't even haircuts they're just
dudes
what the [__] is uh oh boy right there
in the middle yeah with the crazy no I
didn't even tell what that is is that a
tattoo
can we print this for the one right
above them too with the Crazy Design
that's what I mean like oh yeah yeah I
did that a couple times so I can't lie
man oh yeah did you got exotic on him
got an exotic designs on the side you
got the tribal tattoo yeah in your
haircut that's crazy man I was tapped in
bro at an early age yeah but we did see
a barber chair on the side of the
highways what is up with your guys what
are the items on the side of the
highways there's a barber a barber chair
oh oh like you're on the ground
the items on the way here once I got
that idea started writing them down oh
no man what else on the left of the
highway toaster toaster yeah yeah shoe
yeah yeah that makes sense why why why
the loose shoe just one what happens I
see a lotion what the [__] happened
where's the other one someone's barbecue
cover yeah yeah why mattress yeah
standard pillow it came with a I think I
think those are those yeah
uh a Foot Locker t-shirt
I'm not even lying somebody quit on the
way
my
yeah yeah it doesn't make sense man is
there anyone I feel like that's pretty
tame
whatever Highway items no I think our
freeways are definitely we have crazy
and then the shoulders like this big so
there's no room for a [__] toaster
yeah yeah that's true but if no one hits
it though that type of [__] yeah yeah I
think because there's just so many
people especially here the amount of
times I've seen like a mattress or some
[__] just like fly off a truck and the
driver just kind of
yeah what are you gonna do yeah I guess
like side of the highway it's weird to
see [__] but then when you pull off on
an exit you always see the craziest [__]
that's where dudes like builds full-on
like yeah art installations art
installations yeah it's like a burning
man float bro good home sometimes yeah
this is a good setup yeah yeah I know
it's sometimes it's like oh this is a
choice yeah
that's just the San Fernando Valley
right there that's just a hookah bar a
little garage sale